>> Tker: ONE OF O
UNBENDINGULESS D'T G
INVOLV WITTHINGS YOUON'TUNRSTA.
N'TAKE SIDES IN ARGUMTS
YOU DOTEALLY GET.
WE VIOLATED A THE TIME OFURSEECM
METHING REALLINTESTING
THAT'S ECTLYHAT'S HAPNING
WE ARE N TAKINGIDESN THIS
BUT E OF THE BIGGEST
NTRORSIES I SPOS AND MANY
YES IS TING ACE BETWEEN
THE PGA TOUR A AN UTARTOUR
CALL LIV.
DIDN'T OW ECTLY WHAT TO
MAKE OF ITUT ISEEMEDINTERESTG.
LO OF DRA AND O OF
AMERA'S TOP SPORTS
WEECIDED TO GO T TRUMP
BEDMSTER, THE GOL CLUB,
STERY IN NEWERSEAND FIND
T WHAT'S HAPPENG.
TALKE TO E BEST GFERS.
NOW THEOMMISSIONER OF L
TERNATIONAL A ASK, WHY A
U DOI THIQUESTION WERE
GREGORMA
HE'S PT OF T CVERSATIO.WHAT'S T?
YOURE N SNINGO AN
EXUSIVE CTRAC
YOU ARE STRMINGT FORREE.
EY A PTING HUGE AMOUNT
>> TEVENUE WILL COME I ONCWE LA.
TH YEAR IS A STA UP.QUITEONESY R
ERE RE A FEWBSTAES
ROWNUR WAY FROM TH
PGA TOUR.
>>ucker: CAN YOUIVE US
SEE OFHOSE OBSCLES
PHIL MICLSONADEOME NOTOIL
COMPLINTARREMARKS ABO THE
SAUD, WHEHE MONEY CAME
OM, SAUDI ARAA.
IT SNOALLEND ICREADKIND OF A MI.
THE A TO CAME I THEY DO
THE RITHINGRYING TO
PRECTHEIR MONOLY.
THE AYERS BACKEDFF A LTLE
BIT SO  HADO RROUP
READY T SIGNULTIE PLAYETWEEK.
D LAUNCH THEEAGU SOE
CIDE TO TAKE A STEP BK,
ANALYZTHE TUATION.
KNEW OUR MOD W WHE IT
WAS.
WE KW THAT IT WAS THERE.
THE NEY S IN THE BAN
WE MADE AN AUSTMT AND W
WORKEDROUN ERY OBSTACLE
THAT'SEEN THROWN IN O PATH
WE CAMEP WI THE
INVITIONALERIE
WITHHE FS WE DID SURYFOR NEAR 1E
WOD AING FANS FROM DIFFENT
ARE EY MSING?Y LIKE AND WHA
THEY CAMEP OVERWHELMINY,
RE F ENGEMENT.
MORE FAN EXPIENC.
AM SPORT.
VE US MORE TM.AT'SHAT W BUILT TD
OUND
OU MODEL I 100 BUI AROD
E GU ECOSYST FRO THE
OUND UP.
WERE NOTRYINTO DESTROY T
WERE TY ARE T WORK WHIN
THE OSYSTEM  SHOW TT IT'
IT'S MULBILLION-DOLLAR
INDUSTRY.
>> Tker: WHY WOULD SPONSS
PARTIPATG IN LIV?
>> TUCKER,HAT BLOWS MY MI.
SPONRS WPEND MILONSF
DAHTERS IN SAUDIRABI
>> Tucker: THAS A OD
CAN Y GIVE  EXALES?
>> THE PGA TOU THINK HAS
OUT 27 SNSORON THE
PGTOUR THROUGH 4PLUSILLION
ANALASIS IN SAU ARABIA. ON AN
WHDOESN'T THE PGTOURALL
E CEOs OF --
SAYING THATE CAN'TOUSINESS
TH YOU BAUSE YREOING
BUSINESS WITSAUDARABIA?
WHY ARE THEFAKING ONPRESSIONALO?
LE PROFESSNALOLFERS.
THEYL PGAOUR IPONSED,
WON'S GOLFN TH WORLD.NOONE RD SS
WHAT HAVE WE DONE WRONG?WHERE DR
WEAVE A RIG TO PLA ANYERE
IN THE WORLD?
Tucr: IT'S OLLYOT
OUT INCIPLE SO WHAS IT?
>> IT ONOPOLY.
EY WANT TO SHUTS DOWN.
THEYILL LOS WHAVER LEVERAGE
POINT THE CAN.
TH'RE NOT GOINGOHUT US
DOWN BECAUSE T PDUCT SPEFOR ITS,
WE GET CLS EVERYAY FROM
AYERS.
I NT IN.CA I JOI
TEL THEM, SRY, THE SP I
OSE .
THE ST GETS LONGE AND LONGER
R THE PLAYERS WHO WANTO CO
INIT'S AESTANT TO T RIG
ITE NOISE.
>> Tucr: WHY IS IT SO
OFNSIV TO SOME AMERIN GOLF
WHAT AREHEY MADBOUT>> I DON KNO.
ANDE SEHATPPORTUNI NOTCH AI WANL
JUSTOR T MEN BOR THE
WON.
SEET FOR NCA ANDOUNGER
GERATIS.
OPPORTUNITIESOR T KIDS TO
EXRIENCE THE NEWUT THERE
LIV IS THE FUTE OF GOLF.
IT'S VERY SILE SPLE PHRA
ANCOMMENT.
LIVS T FUTURE OF GF.
YODON'T SEE WT WEEE ITHEFURE.CSN
PROGMS, ALL THE SFF TT WE
D GROWI THEAME OF GOLF.F
THEOEEPEADING THAT Y
OFRED SEN, $800 BILLN T
TIGEWOODS?
THATUMBE WAS OUT THERE
FORE I BAME O.
AT NBER HAS BEE O THERE,
S.
SOOURSYOU GOT TO LOO AT T
BE OTHE BES.THE ORINALL AROACD G
BEFO I BAME CEO SO YES TT
MBERS SOMEWHERE I THA
NEHBOROD.
I WOULD Y.IG NUMR.
CALL ME SMALL-TIM
WHATS DONALD TRP'S
CONNECTI?
WE ARET HIS GOLF CLUB.
>> I HAVE KNO DONALD A LONG
ME.
PLAD WI GOLF -- LF WH
M BEFE HE WASRESIDENTI HA DONE D
HIS PASSION F T GAME OF GOL
IS ASASSIATE AS HEAS BEE
A PRESENT ERE STAR &
STRIPE FLO THROUGHIS BLOOD.
HE LES GF AND HEEES THE
COMMCIAL OPPORTUNITY A WHAGO CAM
UMP DMINSTER ISO
DIFFENT.
THE MEMBERSH HE IULL.
'S A CMERCLNTIT
ITN OPERATION WRE HE CAN
KE REVENUE OUTFT.SOHEN WE FIRST,
VIOUSLYS A ART UP, NEEDE
VENUES
WE WEREN DIUSSIONS WH H
AND  NOTIATED A VEN THE
WI HIMND HE LOVED IT.
HE'S BEEN IN T BACKGROD BU
IN THE FOREGROD
HE'SEEN FANTTIC IS WEEK.
HE IS NOPUTTG HIMSE OUT I
ONT OFIV.HEAS ERACED IT.
HE WALKS TO TH FIR TEE, HEWI ALH
I THINIT'S FANTASTIC.
I HA BEE WIT H EVE DAY.
IT'SN OORTUTY FOR US
BEUSE EY'RE GAT VUES.
PLAYS LE IT.
GREAT OPPORTUTYOR US TO
SHOWCASE.
WALKED THROUGH WITH00EMBERS
THUGH THE MEMBE SECON OF
THE CBHOU.
THANK YO ANDHE ENERGY AND
APPRIATEHAT YOUE DONE HE
I'VE NEVER SEEOUR SS SO
HAPPYYOVE DE THIS FOREDMITER.
FORT.ALLY, RLLY  THANK YOU
IT'SUST INCDIBL
FROM AOMMIIONER SNDPOT,
IT'S EXHAUING METIMES  GO
AROU 600EOPLE AND DOHAT
BUT IS SO REWARDINGO HEAR
E FEEDBA FROM THEM
TH AUALLY RE-ENERGES ME.
SO IUST DID THAT FOREOMING
TO